MATT: So what was your talk on?
ADDY: It was on DevTools.
MATT: That you have around.
Current DevTools.
ADDY: It was on DevTools.
MATT: So what
like, specifically,
was it like the new
stuff that's landing?
ADDY: It was like-- there was
a bunch of different stuff.
It was like a grab bag
of new tips and stuff
that we've landed over
the last couple of months.
There was a performance
case study in there
on the Wikipedia
editor, and there
were some more tips and tricks.
MATT: Like what?
Go on and show me.
ADDY: All right, I'll
show you some stuff.
So another thing
we've recently added
is a feature called the
Cubic Bezier Editor.
So people are probably
used to using something
like Lea Verou's
cubic Bezier sites
for like playing around with
different Bezier functions.
It's like helping
visualize them.
So you go in and set like
a preset you like using,
see what that effect
looks like in real time.
MATT: With that
particular curve.
Nice.
ADDY: Exactly, now, this is
sort of third-party tool.
What will be even more useful
is if you just got this natively
available directly
inside your DevTools,
and that's something
we've recently added.
So here, for example,
I'm just going to go,
and I'm going to select
one of these boxes.
And what you'll
now see is we get
these nice little
cubic Bezier curves.
If you click on them,
you'll see we've
got a brand new cubic
Bezier editor here.
You can preview in real
time what each of the Bezier
functions look like.
You can select from a
bunch of different settings
that are available.
You can play around with
the cubic Bezier curve,
and then you can see
what this looks like,
so it's applied right
to the page in line.
MATT: As you'd
expect from DevTools.
ADDY: As you'd
Now another thing
that we've added
is a whole set of
different presets.
So you can see we've got
Ease-in Ease-out, In [? Sine ?],
In Quadratic-- all
of these settings,
so you don't have to
go and Google them,
find them out yourself.
MATT: It's kind of nice being
able to see them already
in DevTools, because,
I've got to say,
I think I normally just
stick to ease-in, ease-out
because I don't know
any of the names.
That's really nice.
ADDY: Maybe with
this tool you'll
learn to learn some new stuff.
MATT: Yeah, I need
to learn more things.
ADDY: So the next one we're
going to take a look at
is the web animation
playback feature.
So here we've got an
animating 3D Nintendo
controller, NES controller.
MATT: Sweet.
ADDY: And the first
thing I'm going
to do is inside of
[? stalls, ?] you know,
where you can usually see all
of the different like margin
and padding and stuff
inside this box--
MATT: That's so nice.
ADDY: Well, you can now see
all the different points,
which the 3D objects defined.
MATT: You get guidelines
and everything.
ADDY: Exactly.
That's not what I
want to show you.
What I want to show you is
the new playback control
we've added.
MATT: I don't care what
you want to show me.
That's it.
I'm done.
ADDY: So now you can
pause your animation.
So here I'm pausing
my CSS animation.
I can control the
speed of playback.
So let's say you want to get
your animation timing just
right.
This is really useful for that.
MATT: Nice.
So it feels like DevTools has
basically done a load of work
on animations because the
combination of those two things
is pretty badass.
ADDY: So there's a
lot more coming down
the line on animations.
I'm not going to
show you right now,
but it's some neat stuff
that you might find useful.
MATT: Nice.
ADDY: So another new
feature we've added
is the ability to export
your logged console messages.
So we're inside the
Google I/O app right now,
and it's logging some
messages to the console,
but let's say that I wanted to
share this with somebody else.
I can now right click
directly inside the console.
I can hit Save As,
and that's just going
to export all that information.
Locally, we can go.
We can check it out
directly inside of Chrome,
and there we go.
We can see all the
messages are there.
MATT: Nice.
Does that support console
tables and groups and all that.
ADDY: I think it's for
its tables just yet,
but that could be an interesting
feature for the future.
MATT: Rubbish.
ADDY: And another thing
I wanted to show you
was if you're in
the Google I/O app,
there's a little
console Easter egg
in there first for getting an
ASCII left shark animating.
MATT: You can't go
wrong with a left shark.
ADDY: Oh, no, you
can spend hours
just like looking at this.
MATT: Yeah, we were worried
about you the first time
you discovered this.
We nearly had the intervention.
ADDY: --several weeks ago.
MATT: Yeah.
You need to do more work is
basically the premise of this.
ADDY: You mean some
work, any work.
MATT: Yeah, if you
could just turn up,
that would be a step
in the right direction.